(applaudissements)
- Le rideau tombe sur le sommet,
satisfaits, semblent prêts
à quitter l'Indonésie.
Mais la rencontre réservait
encore une surpriseeaeaeaeaeaean
de la délégation canadienne
a capté un moment étonnant,
un rare coup d'oeil dans
les coulisses deanananananananae
le président chinois et
le premier ministre du Canada.
"Tout ce dont nous avons
discuté a été divulguéx,x,x,x,xt
inapproprié", a déclaré
Xi Jinping par l'entremise
de son interprète.
avait abordé avec Xi Jinping
la qststion de l'ingérence
chinoise dans les élections
canadiennes. Le bure p p p p p t
rendu public le contenu
de cette conversation.
"Et ce n'est pas mmmme ça que
la conversation s'est déroulée",
ajoute le président chinois,
lui reprochant d'avoir déformé
la vérité. Justin Trudeau tente
une réplique.
"Nous croyons à la liberté det.
Nous tenterons de travailler
ensemble de manière
constructive, mais il y auraquqs
nous ne serons pas d'accord."
les conditions gagnantes",
coconclut Xi Jinping, avant de i
serrer la main et de lui tourner
le dos.
Tout près, la cheffe de cabinet
de Justin Trudeau semble
déconcertée par la scène
qui vient de se dérouler
GUGUGUGUGUGUGUGUGUGUGUGUGUGUGUGn
ambassadeur du Canada en Chine
- Clairement, il était agité,
il était pas content et puis,
moi, à nouveau, je trouvee,e,e,,
ce qu'il a dit à M. Trudeau.
- Encore des tensions, alors que
le Canada vient de durcir
sa politique étrangère pour
faire contrepoids à la Chine.
- Ce que ça confirme, c'est que
les
le Canada et la Chine ne sont
pas prêtes de s'améliorer.
- Justin Trudeau refuse
de dire si cet épisode risque
d'endommager encore plus
la relation entre les deux pays.
Lui et Xi ont unvivision
différente de la transparence,
a-t-il expliquSTSTSTSTSTSTSTSTS,
premier ministre du Canada
- Il y a une réalité que nos
systèmes sont très différents.
des questions des médias,
je ne suis pasffffusqué
quand on me met au défi.
- Il persiste et signe.
- Je pense que les gens savent
très bien que pas toutes les
conversations vont toujours être
faciles avec les autres chefs.
- Justin Trudeau dit vouloir
collaborer avec la Chine
quand c'est nécessaire et
la confronter quand il le faut.
Le premier ministre vient
de ce qu'il peut en coûter de
tenir tête à une superpuissance
comme la Chine. 90 secondes qui
pour longtemps.
Ici Louis Blouin,
Radio-Canada,